the
quarterback of the indianapolis colts
getting set to take on the ravens in a
big monday night football game for both
joining both joining us on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line is carson
wentz thanks for calling carson
appreciate it
absolutely thanks for having me how are
you feeling how are you doing good okay
i'm good yeah no feeling good excited
for this one i i couldn't help but
notice on the injury report it just says
ankle it no longer is plural carson is
that true no longer progress that's
progress yeah no doubt definitely
definitely the one was the the main
issue um this whole time anyway so uh
but no they're they're in a pretty good
pretty good place um the last couple
weeks um
unfortunately nothing happened in the
game so they've been resting and healed
up and uh feel pretty good i'm knocking
on wood here on my head over here in los
angeles what is it like playing a
national football league game at
quarterback with two sprained ankles
carson i've never heard of that before
what is that like
yeah i mean it was definitely a
challenge you know definitely no excuse
but i knew i knew my limitations i you
know i probably never felt
those limitations to that extent as far
as trying to make a play and everything
but i still felt confident in my ability
to to drive the ball throw the ball from
the pocket um and you know the one a
couple weeks ago obviously just didn't
make enough plays and left some out
there but uh yeah it was it was
definitely different knowing i wasn't
going to try and extend plays or pick up
first down with my with my legs no i
mean you were spatted to the hilt man i
mean i'm looking at the photograph right
here uh and and i and i know that you
know that that quarterbacks don't like
talking about injuries because as you
just pointed out no excuses it kind of
comes across sounding like an excuse but
you have to you know with the your foot
that required surgery in training camp
kind of got blown up on you in a new
place in a new spot which is pretty big
for you and i know that you know your
availability in philadelphia was a
conversation perhaps too much for your
liking i i mean are are you
finally do you think knock on wood
finally trending in the right healthy
direction for you and you could just now
take the first quarter of the season and
put that in the out box carson yeah i
mean i i really think the last couple
years i mean first of all when you
started to play football injuries happen
like that's just part of the game that
you know you just try and limit yourself
from from the big ones and do everything
you can to to set yourself up for
success and i feel like i've done that
really the last couple years um little
things here and there always happened
but um yeah i feel confident my ability
to be healthy to stay healthy um but i
also know what i signed up for i know
what i know what this game brings and um
when you got big guys chasing after you
uh every play and you know you it
happens it can happen so i'm doing
everything i can um i'm confident in my
ability to be available um but i also
know that uh
you just never know what about your um
your radar to knowing who plays over
carson how are you doing on that one
carson wentz yeah definitely i mean
learning that one ever since
ever since i came into the league um and
always just trying to to balance the
competitive edge and the and and being
disciplined you know and finding that
balance um so it's never perfect there's
always plays in a game where i'm like
okay maybe could have just called that
one quits or um but there's always some
on the other side too it's like i threw
that one away but i had more time and i
missed that receiver or something like
that so it's always a delicate balance
anytime you're
somebody that can extend the play and
likes to create big big plays that way
you're always going to be telling that
line carson wentz here on the rich eisen
show prior to monday night football
between the ravens and the colts uh in
week five that just began last night do
you watch the thursday night game did
were you able to take any of that in
carson
i did not i don't i don't get around to
watching a ton of football now with
with family um and the family that's
growing you know when you're at home
it's it's often time to time and those
sorts of things so how old are you
how old are they how old are they um we
got about 18 month old and another one
um coming here in about a month or so so
you know definitely changes uh your
family time a little bit
you mean daddy doesn't get to put the tv
on is that what you're saying carson
we still watch tv it just you know it
looks a little different and then you
know quality time with the family just
not always just watching uh thursday
night football okay so it's more elmo
than uh than russell wilson is that what
you're saying in the car
we try not to turn the tv on uh too much
okay um
for those of the little ones but every
now and then we all need to get a break
so we'll find some cartoon movie or
something fun to watch all right uh so
uh the concept of you and frank reich
being sort of you know the uh peas in
the pod that he um
unlocks you in a way that uh of others
um do not and that you respond to his
coaching in a way that um
you you did not with maybe others is
that a fair
assessment of your relationship carson
once and um
i mean it's hard to say
that that way exactly but i think frank
does definitely
um you know challenge me and push me and
coach me
um in a way that i
i like i respect i enjoy um and it
challenges me and it's fun it's been fun
ever since i got here um
but the nice thing i love about frank is
i know where his heart is i know where
he's coming from and at the same time um
i can challenge him too you know we're
we're not afraid to to challenge each
other on certain conversations and
really um have healthy conflict so to
speak and try and drive this bus forward
together uh it's been fun it's been a
lot of fun and a man that i have
respected ever since um really before
even the draft when i got to know him in
the pre-draft process and now working
together with him for a couple years in
philly now getting back together he's
still the same guy that i that i truly
respect and enjoy working with every day
what's an example of that if you don't
mind me prying a little bit more because
i the coach quarterback um relationships
are really the special sauce in the nfl
and many times the difference between a
winning and losing franchise carson you
got one for me with what yeah no i think
it's just i think it's just the healthy
conflict within
hey here's a scheme that we're running
or here's a route concept that we're
running and you know i'd like to see
this you'd like to see this or hey we're
getting
zone here and what what what check do
you want to go with why i like this one
well you like this okay well let's talk
about what's hash it out um or why do
you like that one you know i'm he's not
afraid to ask me that i'm not afraid to
ask him that um and it's really healthy
you know i think because we both
mutually respect each other it's not
like okay i'm questioning you just to
question you it's like hey we're
questioning each other because we just
want to win we just want what's best for
this team um and ultimately uh it gets
us in the right direction and he does a
great job um and again that mutual
respect is the reason you can you can
have those conversations and i know
you're on the same page but we're gonna
about to i'm gonna attempt to go back in
in the book here is that something you
were not getting in philadelphia towards
the end of your tenure there i wouldn't
say that i wouldn't say that um you know
i definitely think we we've always had
that and i'm i've always been wired that
way i think it's just it's just to a
greater extent here with frank and um
and the fact that he also um you know i
guess backed up jim kelly and has the
the the backup knowledge i know that
your head coach was a backup quarterback
as well i'm just again trying to
figure out why why this works so well
and obviously you know you you're
looking for more wins so far this year
i'm just trying to see
why you think this works so well it's
pretty neat to be honest with you yeah
carson now yeah it's hard to hard to put
finger on it you know i thought um
things were
uh
in philly that's just how they how they
went and um you know there's a season
that you know i choose to just move past
and new start new beginning and um but
you know no hard feelings and i thought
my time there was great and uh you know
it's
it's just the the nfl it's just the way
things go change happens and change
happens fast and uh here we are so and
here we are against the ravens carson
wentz monday night football whole
country chilling out watching what's
your challenge what are you seeing on
film so far what do you got for me on
that front yeah uh i mean it's a good
defense there's no doubt about it they
fly around they make things um
try to make things complicated um and so
you just gotta be disciplined you gotta
you know be on on top of your game um
when it comes to protections and
understanding communication and all
those things getting the right checks
um and you know i played played them
twice and they're still the same style
defense i mean they're going to be
physical they're going to come after you
they're going to try and hit you and be
the most physical team on the field um
so we're going to have to bring it um
up front and really in all phases of our
game
um bring the physicality and then you
know just make more plays than that and
then uh last one for you carson uh a
first career start for fellow north
dakota state bison uh trey lance coming
up this weekend do you have any
relationship with him conversations any
piece of advice for trey lance from you
yeah i definitely did get to know trey a
little bit over the last couple years
and even going into the pre-draft
process
um great kid great kid got a great head
on his shoulders and loved his
upbringing and what he brings from uh
his values and everything and you know i
know he can play you know he can swing
the ball around he's a heck of an
athlete
so i'm excited to see um his career
officially begin and hopefully flourish
and then
what do you want colts fans to know
moving forward here you know as they
they show up in their jerseys as i think
you've probably noticed uh i think the
colts fans lead the league in most fans
showing up in team jerseys than anyone
else carson uh what what do you want
them to know about this one and three
start and the season now entering the
second quarter
right now yeah i mean for us
you know we talked last week and just
said hey it's a long season you know we
we were on three now we're one and three
you know not the start we were hoping
for but at the same time we recognized
hey we played good teams we were in
these ball games
we got a lot of things that that are
good we got plenty to fix um and we're
all kind of learning together as we go
you know there's new faces new things
here um and so for us as a team we're
rallying together and we're very
confident that we're just going to keep
getting better and better as the year
goes
um and so that would be
what i would like to echo to anybody out
there is you know we're confident in
this building despite the record or any
of that that you know we're going to
keep getting better um as the year goes
carson appreciate the time and i always
like leaving people who call into the
show better than when i found them when
i said hello to them baby einstein is
very good stuff for an 18 month old kid
good stuff dvds music
go forward it's great
definitely let the real boss now
kick it up the flow chart uh carson i
think you'll appreciate it seriously the
whole once household
all right i appreciate it thank you take
care of yourself that's carson wentz and
his ankles but only one on the injury
report right here on the rich eisen show
prior to monday night football
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here